[Music]
life is plastic it's fantastic you can
brush my hair undress me everywhere
imagination life is your creation come
on pimpy let's go party
hey babe it's a beautiful
beautiful morning
I want to start the podcast
which I want to start the podcast today
with two questions from ancient Greek
philosophy philosopher Seneca yeah I
grew up off Seneca Avenue in Ridgewood
Queens Brooklyn yeah so it is Sonic has
always been near and dear the Seneca
runs through queens and Brooklyn Seneca
Seneca Avenue runs to Queensland
Brooklyn Seneca the philosopher I don't
know if they named Seneca Avenue after
Seneca the philosopher okay I don't know
but it's two simple questions I have for
you I was hoping we started off this way
this is from Seneca
if not you then who if not now then when
let's talk about it that's who said that
well let me say the first thing that
reminded me of and you are my target
market yes I am that reminds me of and I
used to say this all the time who but
W.B Mason
exactly you know it who but W Mason
every Yankee every Yankee game every
year I always say well like yeah I
always say who but W Mason yeah I don't
know who who but them I I genuinely
here's the thing with WB Mason and it's
no disrespect to WWE Mason I love the
commercials who but Debbie Mason I think
about it brings back memories to my
childhood makes me think of my father I
love it I don't know what Debbie Mason
does or what they provide I have no idea
what their services can't answer it
because I don't know who else should be
doing delivering products to help keep
businesses run smoothly shout out to be
Mason keep doing what you're doing but
for me at chips Nation I gotta be honest
with you for me I use ship station for
all my needs God bless you guys God
bless Only One Stop Shop for all your
shipping needs and that's ship station
yes and the guy on the the picture of
the you know old white guy yeah it's
just not in today it's just that that
kind of look that to me I think of two
words when I see W.B Mason this guy I
think a rape whistle that's what
happened rape whistle I see maybe
uh uh it looks it looks you know a
version maybe an aversion to Jewish
people yes yes I think maybe he looks
also like he runs a Popsicle stand in
Williamsburg yeah he looks a little like
a little Illuminati going he looks like
he would bear knuckle fight you yeah
Barn yeah
um
he looks like my uncle who was touchy at
one point tell you something about you
Sal and I don't know if if you know this
about your people tell this about you
you are one of the guys who you keep it
really together in between haircuts in
between haircuts yeah but you don't look
like I'll text it today to schedule a
haircut because it's due time but it
doesn't look unkempt a lot of guys you
say you know you kind of politely say go
get a haircut yeah you haven't got
you're due for a haircut but also not do
for a haircut it's very it your hair is
right in that zone thank you and you
know that wasn't always like that but
I'll tell you a little secret
if you have medium length hair you can
get away with not getting a haircut for
way longer okay because obviously if you
have very short hair right the growth is
going to be noticeable right but if I
have medium hair to begin with and then
over a month I gain a half inch or an
inch it's not that noticeable it cuts
down on haircuts all together which in
the end makes you have a little bit of
save so you're saying when you go down
to get a haircut you don't ask them you
you sometimes look like you didn't even
get a haircut after a haircut like
family members and Friends a haircut
after a haircut but you but this is the
result like a month and a half later
you'll still be like it's still well put
together it's not like you're in dire
need of haircut but I am but it doesn't
look like it interesting I moved
recently only like in the last couple
years like the pandemic I moved to like
a medium length hairstyle now I was
always you my whole life now do you have
them do your eyebrows when you get a
haircut I've never done my eyebrows in
my life you never even had them shaved
you know you don't even grow unibrow oh
wow yeah you're good not a single Touch
of my eyebrows in my life and I do
wonder if I I sometimes I oh sometimes
I'll like trim like just like neatness
yeah not like a
just like a presentable right right but
you get them you get them no what he
does is my barber is um what he will do
is he'll put a comb in my eyebrow and
shave he'll just [__] you're not going
to get your eyebrows down I used to go
get my eyebrows threaded shout out I
think it was called rikas in uh Liberty
Avenue in a little Guyana uh Queens I
don't Liberty everybody understood what
this is threading and I think it is
painful right and I don't understand how
they have the skill to Target one strand
of hair and then rip it one by one
people got skills out there y'all got
skills people got skills you you've had
this done to you what does it feel like
that's what they used to do to me and
little Guyana in Ozone Park have you
been a little guy Anna no you got to go
to little Guyana on Liberty Avenue I was
on Park it's fun it's the neighborhood
it's called Little Guyana yeah like how
there's Little Italy what happens there
there's just a bunch of Guyanese people
okay I used to date a girl who was guy
and he's loved her she's changed her
phone number though where's Guyana
Guyana is um Brazil but they're near
Brazil but they look um like a lot of
people be like oh they like the
Trinidadian Tobago they kind of have a
India Tobago and Trinidad is so fun
Trinidad and Tobago it's just so fun
it's it's probably the best geographical
name Trinidad and Tobago yeah yeah
because it's too it's what other
countries are two names
you got Trinidad and Tobago you got um
uh uh uh what's the one um there's
there's another one and something
um
Trinidad what's the one like where they
filmed uh Dubrovnik Croatia but not that
Serbian Montenegro oh okay Serbia and
Montenegro is like that's one name yes
okay you ever seen the you ever seen the
lines on the map of Croatia Serbia and
Montenegro I can't say that I have pull
this up what crew what Croatia did was
such as [__] you move is when they made
their borders they just took the entire
Coach line look at this they took the
entire Coastline see Croatia and they
left Bosnia at not eight not still
Bosnian no that's Bosnia is still called
Bosnia I think okay yeah it was the
former Yugoslavia is is one okay but you
see Montenegro has a little sliver
Serbia and montenego but literally the
country of Serbia they said you can suck
my ass you're not getting Ace a drop of
natural ocean water Croatia took the
whole thing yeah and that's why honestly
I have that literally on my list of
vacation destinations Croatia they're
gaining from that because of of the
water side of course as opposed to I'm
not like let me go to herzegovania and
here's why I like Croatia you ready for
this I like Croatia's flag because it
always makes me hungry because it looks
like the top of a pizzeria tablecloth
that's it look at the Croatian flag and
tell me you don't think tablecloth
Pizzeria tablecloth right away look at
that right there that's what it is
classic Pizzeria looks like Joe and
John's Pizzeria shout out Joe and John's
in in Ridgewood great pizza I think
they're going to be catering uh the
green room when I do my show Radio City
oh wow and Shout Out Taste of Pueblo
taco truck they're going to be catering
my show at the theater at MSG on
September 23rd we're still on some
tickets available so we're gonna have
Puerto Rican night and Italian night
nice oh that's cool and then what are
they just come in and deliver it and
show you having a reception after both
well I'm just gonna have it in the Green
Room for people on ganache okay you know
why the hell not it's thoughtful
thoughtful and maybe we'll do something
where we'll get like we'll do some kind
of Lottery thing and we'll get five fans
who come to the show they can come back
and have some food
what if we do that well be careful the
checks that you're writing because
you've got to cash them yes you got to
cash them once okay yeah just be careful
so I have experience right because
that's going to take a minute to put
something together there right and then
do you really want to pull people in the
back and then you have to be taken away
from your family forget I said that
no do what you want I'll help you do it
no now what's this top countries with
the weirdest names we got did you booty
did you booty did you booty Azerbaijan
Azerbaijan let me tell you something
about Azerbaijan I once when I was
single went on a date with the girl from
Azerbaijan never was maybe the most
beautiful woman I've ever seen in my
life besides Jasmine and my mom
um but Azerbaijan and vanitya Azerbaijan
was the girl was gorgeous I I it was
like
azerbaijani in women and also I don't
know if you ever if you've ever seen a
random Swedish woman but they look like
they're from other planets like they're
random like well like she's just
stumbles across the street random sweet
okay they have these blonde hair and
blue eyes and the azerbaijanian women or
the azerbaijani women that I met just
looked like she wasn't of this planet
like she was something else I mean when
you go over the pond right over there
yes uh a lot of these countries
they have the um biggest output of
supermodels but then they also like I
think it's all or nothing over there
sometimes
they had the biggest output of super
every six foot tall supermodel you see
is is from yeah they got one that looks
like one girl that looks like a
supermodel other girl looks like Borat
yeah that's what you get that's you get
that's a roll of dice uh which is we
that's yes Niger which is is it's
Nigeria right no Nigeria and Nigeria are
not the Republicans you just piss people
off no no no not that I thought it said
the Republic of Nigeria because I'm not
wearing my glasses uh I I didn't mean to
piss off any people from the Republic of
Nigeria Nigeria if you by the way if we
have we have Nigerian people on our side
Godfrey The Comedians Nigerian and he
fought he would fight in the Great War
With Us yes can you scroll back to one
shout out Godfrey the Nigerian who is he
pimp
aspergier
no no I'm just saying it's in the is a
country in the transcaucasian region
region the Transat well the
transcaucasian region obviously been
controversial as of late but it's
suggestions
17th and like 28th yeah you could see
you could see members of the
transcaucasian region performing usually
at The Comedy Cellar um in downtown and
um and and transcaucasian region is uh
yeah from between South West Asia and
Southeastern Europe
okay okay can I ask you a question yeah
not to divert but two times this week
I've heard two different people that I
know use
a word incorrectly
okay actually they said the wrong word
in place of what they thought they were
supposed to say
it's been annoying at me but I don't
want to be the person it doesn't matter
actually it doesn't matter to me I do I
have a responsibility I could kill us
what I'm getting is do I have a
responsibility as these people that are
a friend or even a relative to say you
know
just so you know that's not the word
like
what's your what is the etiquette there
like am I am I like not helping am I
doing them a disservice but not letting
them know because they're clearly
walking around Earth saying it wrong
everywhere uh and but I don't want to be
the guy that's like Ah that's how you
say it but that's not what I mean right
I think it borders first of all it
depends on the word it does I'll give
you both it does border on the kind of a
bit pedantic but it's not I don't want
to be pedantic you don't want to be
pedantic so if you don't want to be a
pedantic I want to be helpful but I
think then unfortunately you have to you
have to let people you have to let
people go on as they may you have to let
them walk their own course really yeah
that's what Seneca says I would want you
and we'll go back to Seneca I would want
you to tell me
right I told you about Tupperware and
tupperware right and it went viral it
did go viral yeah I told you about the
girl you said they used to spell
hysterical in the text
h-y-s-t-e-r-i-c-l-e right whatever I
just said which is a more fun way to
spell it yeah but what I would do is I
would write back that something else was
hysterical but then spell it properly
right in hopes that she would you know
right
get clued in and she never did she'd
write back to me hysterical again the
wrong way she might have been like this
guy is spelling it wrong what are the
words the words this week were someone
said something was a mute point
okay of course it's moot it's a moot's
point right mute meaning m-u-t-e which I
get why you would think that because
mute means quiet and so it almost seems
like what it should mean right but it's
mlot moot okay this is the second time
or third time I heard that person say it
in a few years I've known them okay and
so I'm like ah well you should say it's
it was a one-on-one situation and then
someone texted me they're in the midst
of something m-i-s-t like yeah right
even if that might have been a typo I
don't know but it's not Emma they didn't
put mids they didn't put the D yeah
and in the Mist also seems like I kind
of get why I'm in the in the middle of
I'm in the midst of something you know
what I mean the way I think to respond
to that especially if it's tax is do
what you've always done is just text
back the proper word and kind of put it
out there kind of just in the universe
and let them figure it out but I think
what if one is a family member fine to
tell him
you don't ever want I don't ever want to
make someone feel like I'm making them
feel silly well here's the thing here's
here's where it gets down to yeah you
have to ask yourself what's the reason
you're telling them is it because is it
more of because you and let's just be
honest here we're gonna we're we're
we're talk we started this episode with
if not me then who if not now then why I
was about to apply that right now though
are you is it because you want to is it
more of there's two reasons why you're
doing this okay is it more that your ego
and you not ego in a bad way how we all
have an ego your ego your little inner
personality saying I want to correct
them because that would make me feel
better or is it I actually want to help
them or is it like Taylor Swift says is
it is it your self-guided narcissism
disguises altruism
that's what Taylor Swift says it's a
lyric fine fine
it's me at T time everybody agrees
I I you know I don't I I don't know if I
know any of our songs
I I know that she's the most popular
person on the planet and do you know who
she's dating no now I don't Maddie Healy
from The 1975 the lead singer which is
why I've you you said Chris this is the
thinnest I've ever seen you've lost
weight and I made up this whole lie
about oh I'm fast when I'm working out I
haven't eaten since I found out the news
that Maddie Healy stick to my stomach
about it because it's it's Maddie is in
New York now multiple times a month and
I don't get to see him and I've never
met has word gotten back yet after all
the mentions I think what's happened is
is I think I took the bit a little too
far and actually wound up pushing them
away I think I got them close I had them
close I actually have shout out Ross
from The 1975 cell phone number I've
texted him two or three times nothing I
think the bit about them not liking me
it was all just a bit it was just a ruse
to get them to you know I neg them okay
and then I think I pushed it too far and
now they're like this guy is getting a
little Annoying now and I you know well
what can I do I I am only who I am and
you know if not if not if not me then
yeah yeah you know as epictia says the
real man it the real man is revealed
during hard times and I'm during hard
times right now and the real man is me
right now and I'm saying that I made a
mistake the real man is is one of Truth
so if if the 1975 is watching and assume
they are yeah this is what you have to
say to them and I think if the ball is
in their court now it's in their court
all their balls can be in my court I'd
love nothing more yeah you should call
yourself the Christmas ethanol seriously
right or I should just name my next
comedy special the 1975. that's what you
should not or that won't push him away
drop the the and just say it's called
1975.
1975 the band my newest comedy special
um so so you have to so you wait what
did Taylor Swift say real quick again
um
don't disguise your is your basically
the I forget the lyric is that you just
disguising your naturalism with altruism
like some congressman
right like they're they're self-serving
exactly like when the congressman go out
there so I want to help the migrants no
you want to get reelected right you
don't want to help you're you're just
got your it's your narcissism disguises
altruism okay that's what it is I mean
not every politician does that right
that's just what Paul you know to even
want to be a politician is the ego to
the fullest how did Taylor Swift become
the biggest musical act in the history
of our world kids history of our world
kids my she's as big as she's bigger
than the [__] my daughter my daughter
is eight just turned eight years old
happy belated happy birthday baby we had
a great party great Barbie Barbie theme
party was amazing somebody dropped uh
half of her cake in the pool
um it was amazing shout out Mark's bake
shop on Staten Island made the cake
unbelievable cake you need any type of
candy shop on Staten Island let me tell
you something Sal you need to go there
you deviated from a piece of cake
I love piece of cake I just want a piece
of cake is amazing my go-to's now are
piece of cake of course like always take
it up with Bloom Cafe take everything up
with Bloom Cafe on Staten Island at any
time you gotta take it that's what you
take it up with but and piece of cake is
amazing shout out to cannoli Donuts but
Mark's bake shop they make custom donuts
and you know they have they have daily
Donuts they have these egg sandwiches on
croissants and the birthday cakes we've
had we get our cakes from them for
everything now we're unbelievable on uh
is it is um where you know Bagel Depot
Like Home Depot but for bagels Casey uh
Casey um
had a great bit about that remember when
he did a bit about Old Bagel stores no
case
um uh Casey Jost okay he did a bit and
he called Bagel it's The Bagel Depot
It's Like Home Depot but for bagels it
was funny but you don't know where The
Bagel Depot is I think it's on Richmond
okay butcher box I love it especially
summer's coming out it's grilling season
I need meat on that Grill I need meat in
my mouth I go with butcher bugs do I
really use every product on our show
let's be honest with each other I don't
do I check every project out yes do i do
do I do something if I think it's no
good no but I use butcher box I do use
Butch and same with me I use butcher box
they it just what it is is they just
literally send me to your house you sign
up for it you pick the meats you want
and they deliver it right to your mouth
right to your mouth right to your house
and it's literally it's just always they
got no hormone no antibiotics in the
meat humanely raised they got grass-fed
beef free-range chicken pork raised
crepe free wild caught Seafood it's high
quality means Seafood you can try trust
and they're going to give us a sweet
deal right now yes for the listeners
what is it babe uh sign up today using
Code hey babe to receive ground beef for
a year it's amazing plus 20 off your
first order okay this is gonna be free
shipping you can curate the box or you
can pick one of their customized ones
that's delivered to your doorstep it's
two pounds of ground beef free in every
box for a year plus 20 off your first
order when you sign up at butcherbox.com
hey babe and use our code hey babe
what's up everybody listen I got a brand
new hour of standard material and I'm
shooting a comedy special in Atlanta in
December I don't have the exact dates
yet but just know in Atlanta December
I'm coming to you and I am putting on a
slew of cities from September to
December so see tell me if you don't see
your city there hit me up on at Christy
comedy on social media and tell me if
you want me to come to your city but
they're here September 23rd right now
has tickets left the theater at Madison
Square Garden New York City Radio City
September 22nd is sold out so go get
your tickets at Chris D comedy calm for
my fall tour in Atlanta I'm coming to
you to do my species I love it too I am
filming my special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd and thus I am
also kicking off a tour I will be all
over the place Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Ohio Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Wilmington Delaware Torrington
Connecticut uh Macon Georgia you ever go
there no
Savannah Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria
Rockford Springfield Olen Illinois
Duluth Appleton Rochester Minnesota uh
I'm gonna be all over I'm gonna be uh
like I said in Hartford and I'm going to
be in Syracuse doing some clubs and some
theaters that'll all be announced very
very soon but if you want to see me
right away you just see me on tour with
the guys in practicaljokerslive.com uh
this weekend coming up we're on Columbus
Cleveland Detroit then Minneapolis Des
Moines Kansas City and then we close out
in Nashville Indianapolis in St Louis
all those tickets are on sale right now
at impracticaljokerslive.com
where's Mark's Bake Shop Richmond Road
you are someone
you're the type of guy
that explores commits
and then well Jasmine would disagree
with you on the commitment
you explore you commit and then you
you promote yes you are have been living
on Staten Island for how long by the way
shout out Mark and Amanda great people
they were at the party I've been living
on Staten Island since the people who
baked the cake were invited to the party
Mark and Amanda have become friends yeah
they're they're love they're great kids
and they came and they didn't know it
was a pool party so they came fully
decked to the nines and just kind of
stood around so they made the case they
made the cake and delivered and then
stayed as guests unbelievable great
people and they brought me a bottle of
uh uh Casa de regrones Tequila so really
good people this is what I'm saying how
long have you been on Staten Island
since September of 21. Staten Island is
you're approaching two years I've been
there for 46. right you no more
businesses than me you frequented more
businesses than me you befriended more
businesses than me and you know of more
businesses than me but you went in
if I may testicles deep yes on Staten
Island businesses and supporting local
shops yes and then doing your part to
help them in their Journey yes uh I find
it fascinating uh I don't know how
you're discovering all these businesses
and they're all gangbusters and then you
you have the the wherewithal to come on
here and then give them a little thank
you publicly which is also very nice
are you getting free stuff all over
Staten Island into any place you walk
into so it maybe this kind of goes as
the narcissism disguises altruism here
but I know that we can lead to that but
what I would say is Mark by the way Mark
has been ver Mark's big shop uh have
been very generous and have given me
multiple cakes for free but I've also
bought and spent many because I want to
support that business so the money
supports the small businesses so that so
they've done you know
um done it both ways same with Bloom
Cafe you know they give me free food
when I go in there try this try that but
you know we support support the business
um but I think
sometimes when it comes to business and
promotion because you know within our
industry our agents or they'd say don't
give anybody free shout outs they have
to pay for it but I think there's a
negative karmic energy attached to the
money if I'm only doing it for the money
I think I think then that I actually
wouldn't want them to I wouldn't want to
pay for it no in this local scenario a
local shop right I mean until until
people's ears bleed shout them out yeah
I mean I'm not going to be like you know
hey I love Costco right right yeah right
because because really if we're going to
go you know the thing is go shop locally
if you don't want to do locally then
it's hello fresh all day America's
number one meal kit that's right and
also I really do love Costco
so do I
um so so you're saying okay what was the
question so you really you I I am
impressed because it's consistent
and we were talking recently and I know
that you I know that where you live now
is an on foot traffic area right but I
feel like
you it doesn't matter I feel like you
like take me through a day like how do
you discover these new places are you
googling do you have a need and then you
Google it and then you say oh here's a
place then let me go to it are you
driving and making mental notes and then
saying let's just pull in here real
quick let me just pull in here real
quick and like discovering like are you
like a Staten Island Magellan my thought
yes shout out Ferdinand Magellan my
thought process with just living is I'm
only going to get one spin on this
planet so let me try whilst I'm here the
universe is always changing and
expanding so let me rather than
absolutely I want to find place things
that I like foods that I like places
that I want to go that make me feel good
but why not try it doesn't happen every
day but at least not try every day to
try one thing new in my life and then by
the time my life is at the end I'll have
tried as much as I could right okay so
two things one do you really keep that
up here every day I do really really
really really I swear to God right now
are you trying to do try or experience
something new each day what I've been
like how do you keep up with that so I
have a list I have a list that me and my
uh my my neighbor Chris Pena have of of
places that we want to go to on Staten
Island like new places that have opened
mostly restaurants and stuff like that
but also I also have your list that that
you gave me of the parks all the parks
the mount Loretta Park and all those
parks that I've went I've knocked them
off Snug Harbor so on a day that you
have
free free time you you've refer to that
and try to go do it if I have if not
every day like today I didn't have any
time today I didn't have any time to do
that today what I did to try to be a
little different is I've been eating a
lot of eggs I've been eating eggs almost
every morning and so today what I did
was I've been wanting to try oatmeal
from uh this place by a bar in Brooklyn
and I went and got the oatmeal there and
it was great so you drove into Brooklyn
I worked out in Brooklyn and the bot
where I went to badass Academy shout out
badass that's I love working out there
and then I went to badass Academy on Bay
Ridge Avenue in Brooklyn and they have a
buy a bar attached so I ate the oatmeal
from there and it was amazing so now
I've added some now I'll add that in and
said now it's something that you like
and you'll frequently right because I
was just eating I was just going to
Manor Bagels every day on Manor Road and
just getting egg whites avocado raw
onions ketchup on whole wheat wrap and I
got it delicious I got it for too long
do you have any fear about eating eggs
every single day with cholesterol my
because my lady eats eggs for the
morning frequently so much so that I had
to be like I don't think we should be
doing this well she told me that's a
fallacy it's not uh well the the whole
idea of high in cholesterol but yeah but
they say cholesterol isn't as isn't as
um bad as they make it up that's what
they say it's about the ver the balance
what's your high cholesterol versus your
low cholesterol what's your total
cholesterol what's your triglycerides
all those things come into play I
actually though with all the working out
and all that I've been doing went to the
doctor last week and I still have high
cholesterol it's lower than it was but
it's still why are you eating egg whites
or eggs because if it's high now you
shouldn't eat eggs I've been eating
cheese the doctor told me not to worry
though because my good cholesterol the
HDL is the highest it's ever been you
want your good cholesterol to be high
and your bad cholesterol the LDL to be
low a lot of people have low good
cholesterol and high bad cholesterol
I'll never understand it really yeah
what is the good cholesterol do to you
the good bad cholesterol doesn't the
good cholesterol the HDL is kind of acts
like almost like a cleaner of your
arteries and goes in and cleans out the
bad cholesterol which is just fat little
pieces of [__] that gets stuck to your
artery wall so how do we discern where
we get the good and the bad through our
foods like what's what's good and what's
bad so HDL the good cholesterol
typically gets raised well no typically
gets raised with exercise exercise is
what raises the good cholesterol that's
why exercise is heart healthy the bad
cholesterol the ldls and the
triglycerides get high with eating you
know uh you know Foods saturated with
you know saturated with fat say it
saturated with sat saturated with sad
Foods saturated fat is a fun name
saturate is that the name of the episode
it's a special saturated saturated
saturated sap not exercising yeah no
one's gonna search infatuated status but
I like it yeah the saturated fat I'm
gonna write that should we make it merge
faster rated is that is that the elastic
this city merch saturated sad
lacticity we need to take it up a Bloom
Cafe we need it allegedly we need an
allegiance and then the third spot is
it's got to be elasticity or maybe it's
saturated fat it's it's got to be
saturated sad or shout out something
yeah
right
um
I so I I think um
I think that for me we told my
cholesterol and then the places you
frequent the cholesterol and the places
I frequent do you feel like I feel like
Staten Island is almost like Sesame
Street for you yes like you've you've
made it a neighborhood it's new but
that's why I have a gripe that you don't
have a walking neighborhood right but
guess what I've done guess what I did
yeah you ready for this should I guess
or well take a guess
uh you
you went bungee jumping no okay close
though okay close I did um I have uh I
jumped into my pool uh I was the first
person to test out and we got a new pool
and I was the first person to test out I
was
for sure thought it was seven feet deep
and it was four feet and I landed on my
tailbone oh yeah it was a stinger
um but was it a can opener a
a cannonball Cannonball when you got
kids if you don't if you're the dad you
don't do a cannonball it's like they're
like why are you even my father do you
commit do you have knees to chest until
you unsubmerge as high as I could I
jumped you hold inside tight because I
wanted to make your arms around it yeah
you'll give a maximum Splash Max Splash
film The Jazz filmed it and I I hit like
full blast tailbone spot like could have
actually given myself a cerebral spinal
injury right because I thought it was
seven feet and it is in fact four but
then you could have treated yourself
like true yeah
so here's here's what has happened to me
okay
I've changed my I did say you jumped
that's why I'm saying it's pretty close
so it's close yeah
what I've realized what I've realized is
and this is let's go back to Marcus
Aurelius for a second here what I've
realized is is we've heard you know
rather than worrying about what you
don't have and imagine what you don't
have appreciate what you do have sure or
as Marcus Aurelius put it it is not the
poor man the poor man uh it is it is not
the man who has little
it is not the man who has little but he
who desires more who is poor that's what
Marcus really said is not the man who
has too little is the one who wants more
that's when you're poor that wasn't
Nietzsche that was was if he is he stole
it from he stole it from Marcus Aurelius
okay he's [__] Carlos and
it is not the man who was little but he
who has who desires more is poor and so
what I what I did was because I was
having this struggle I was talking to
you I was talking to friends I want to
sell my house blah blah blah blah I
can't walk anywhere what I did once is I
went back I I did two things one I
looked at what the cost of a house and
what and actually went and visited what
the cost of a house would be and what
the life would be like in a walkable
community in New York city so I factored
in how much higher things would be
staying at home right in homes in
Brooklyn or queen yeah okay yeah you're
not seeing apartment building right
right okay an actual home big money High
interest rates taking kids away from uh
uh you know their their friend group and
all that and then what I did and then I
went back to where I used to live where
I used to live which was all walkable in
Bay Ridge beautiful neighborhood the
neighborhood I want to be in but went
back and actually knocked on the door of
the apartment I used to live in and
asked the great people who live in that
apartment if I could walk back in there
and they allowed me to do it
really I are something yeah you you yeah
because some people do that with their
childhood homes or something [__] but
you lived there like two years ago right
did you and they bought it from you yeah
yeah well they didn't know who you were
when you knocked so I I had an yes they
did that you you broached it I said well
I was you know stepping back and I said
I used to live here and the the woman
was like oh I know I heard that you used
to live here and I said well listen I
said what did you want to see I'll tell
you so what I said was I said you know I
don't obviously you can say no I said to
this woman I said you could say no I
could come back another time I said you
know all I wanted to do if it was
possible no not filming anything nothing
it's just me
to walk back into the apartment and see
what it feels like again because I just
explained this right I said because I
living on Staten Island now and I'm
going through a little bit of back and
forth if this was the right move for me
or not you were vulnerable I was
vulnerable and I said I'm romanticizing
the idea of being back here and I said I
know it's what a wonderful apartment it
was but can I go back in and she was
like absolutely she was like as a matter
of fact the cleaning lady just left come
on in and then what was it like when you
entered that room because now it's just
you and her alone
yeah and what do you say I walked in and
I and I and I you know obviously
complimentary of what they've what they
did well now let's it's just me and you
here right who decorated better did you
walk in and have a permanent Envy you
like mine was better I mean you know the
the last thing the last thing I would
have ever done is put crucifixes all
over an apartment okay and when I walked
in there you know sometimes I would
imagine it might be the first thing you
would do because yeah yeah
and and and so you're like just all over
my body other crucifixes exactly the
apartment if I'm gonna do what I'm doing
permanently so I walked in there and I
said and and I and I you know
complimentary the house was clean it was
as remembered but when I walked back
into the bedrooms because you know I was
thinking about like you know how my
daughter would always say she misses her
room with the with the with no window
um you know Tristan would always say oh
I miss my room because I could look out
into the yard I went in there and then
even I would say like oh remember when
we could just like open the door and
like go in our backyard and and blah
blah blah blah blah I went back in there
and I immediately realized I immediately
realized when I went in back into the
apartment you're living a better life
right I have upgraded my life in so many
ways it's unimaginable yeah man and and
and and so I was like even that was a
great exercise to run it was great to do
something similar and I was appreciative
of of it and and and and and I think
where that family is living now is
amazing it's great for them and it was
great for me when it was when it was
there it was great for me but now when I
got back into my house I literally
almost like wept at what a beautiful
house I have and it fundamentally it
fundamentally changed me and I think
that I'm gonna start to try to do I'm
gonna start to try to try to practice
like
poverty once or twice a month what I
mean by that is not going crazy living
on the street what I mean by that is I'm
just to be more appreciative of what I
have is to go you know instead of
driving in because I have the luxury of
doing that in parking take the ferry
take the two buses sit coach flying to
you know a city
um um just to help appreciate because
then when I get the opportunity because
what's going on
I just heard Chris talking about this in
the other room
looking like Grandma
you didn't know you were here [__]
pig did you just say you're gonna
practice poverty if I fly coach and ride
in the subway
you just described my regular life
30.
[Laughter]
I swear to God I was leaving
I was walking out the door right now and
as I was walking by I heard you say that
that's so crazy
that's so funny you just invited me to
see your house for the rest of my money
he said that's one level above
homelessness
he's like not homeless but like I'll fly
coach I'll take the ferry he said
they could have examples I couldn't
think of anything I'll leave Joey roses
for a while what you meant what you
meant what was that well you you were
gonna cut out daily amenities yes I
meant like you know like you can apply
it to whatever your life is at home like
you know practice poverty
you know what I meant that was one of
the best entrances I've ever seen in my
life that's the clip I mean you came in
I don't know where you surprised us it
was very cream risk but then you really
made a statement yeah
no dude I [__] love it all right love
you man
no I know exactly what you mean I know
exactly what you mean yeah yeah so I'm
gonna try to do it I'm probably not
gonna do any of this but I like to just
say things and put it out there in the
universe you do the things you do them
not all of them don't be like that you
do not all of them if not
you who if not now if not now then when
if not you then who right
that's what it is does that always apply
like if if I'm on the street and I see
some uh a gang of Street toast bullying
someone and I'm like someone's got to
step in and help that person
if not me who if not now when and then I
just go in they just put my teeth down
my throat yeah that's not good what's
this guy's name that said this Marcus
Aurelius what about that situation
Aurelius
it's a good question why is it not a
basketball player Marcus Aurelius
arvida sabonis is a basketball player no
really is uh
there's a guy uh
Aurelius no
something I really is always a
basketball player yeah yeah yeah
um I don't know something it really is
okay he was good he was good he's a star
yeah 10 years ago
Arenas Gilbert Arenas yeah he pulled the
dinosaurs somebody in a club in
Washington DC oh come on Gilbert you're
better than that you build it Go by the
way let me tell you something who if
you're born
and your name is Gilbert and you make
the NBA that's a feat because I wonder
also too he might be the only Gilbert
ever in the NBA and it might be one of
those things that because he was named
Gilbert is what motivated him to be an
NBA player because he was getting made
fun of constantly for his name being
Gilbert
yeah I'll tell you something when do you
think the last time a person named
Gilbert was born
there had to be someone born named
Gilbert today how many people are born
every day yeah do you think this do you
think that nearly every day someone is
born with every kind of main name that
we know of three 185 000 babies a day
140 million babies a year damn how many
people die exactly that was going to be
our next question how many people died
how many people are die every day how
many people die every day how many
people
67.1 million people die a day no no in
2022.
so so half
58 you're right half uh well that's
that's less than half yeah right but
yeah wow so we are we're getting so
every day we're growing by a quarter of
a million people
every single day every second two people
died every second you're dead that's not
that much you're dead you're dead right
so you're just now 20 people died 20
people have died hundred thousands of
people are dead during the midst of this
podcast
even more born that's the beautiful did
that say 385 000 uh oh wait you wait a
second did you just have the Gilbert
statistic one out of every 11 776 baby
boys born in 2021 I named Gilbert I
didn't know we can get these
no is there any girls named Gilbert
how many girls are named Gilbert
if you're a person out there and your
name's Gilbert please write uh write to
us
Gilbert gilberta
Gilbert baby girl name meaning it oh
okay wait wait how many people were born
a day
that's a day four hundred one thousand
three hundred people born a day all
right hold on I got this
let's do it all right that's my bad but
you know let's just ignore it just drop
it who cares 401. I can't believe I
described the Rose's life when I was
trying to make a philosophical Point
what a piece of garbage Joe DeRose is
401 300 divided by what's the eleven
thousand seven hundred and seventy six
that means 34 Gilberts are born a day
that's too many that's so many Gilberts
because I can only think of Gilbert
Arenas 12
131 Gilberts are born a year a year but
I can only think of three Gilbert Arenas
Gilbert Godfrey Gilbert Grape
what other Gilbert do you know that's
famous
Gilbert Arenas Gilbert Godfrey Gilbert I
know a Dilbert comic you know more
dilberts I I know a kid named with a
last name Gilbert no we don't know
anything see this one Gilbert pero like
then you get some hockey players and
hockey players don't care don't count
hockey plays
yeah I don't know another one of these
people I'd love to get Gilbert Arenas on
the podcast have him bring his gun
why not with me now
I don't care as it's not aimed at me
you've ever gun pointed out your weapon
pointed at you
um let me think about this I feel like I
would immediately know if a gun was
probably not oh I was shot out a couple
days ago
oh yeah I was shot I was shot on the
highway did I tell you that no are you
being serious right now yes not I wasn't
sure okay I didn't tell you you're being
dead serious somebody shot at you at the
highway six shots
no no no no I was driving to the airport
they didn't shoot at me okay I'm driving
I got Chris Johnson in the car shout out
CJ and then I got we got a runner and
we're trying to make a a late night
flight and we're driving in Denver and
we're about 10 minutes from the airport
we're on a three-lane highway and we
hear
like two or three bangs or pops followed
by a couple more and it vibrated the car
we all thought it came from the car I
said we just ran over something Chris
said we're backfiring and the driver was
like I thought you punched the ceiling
the car shook
so that was what I thought you punched
the ceiling because we were told funny
things yeah yeah
I don't know we're in the middle of a
conversation I don't know why it was
appropriate but then after like this two
or three shots
we looked out the window and the car two
lanes over so we're in a lovely and
there's a right in the middle Julian's
over the guy is driving his window was
all the way down he has the gun out of
the window and he's shooting it straight
out and he hits it three or four more
empties the whole clip there's fire
shooting from his gun and it's shaking
our car and he's shooting it not here
he's just shooting it like this we are
the car that's here we are the car that
is right here and he is shooting a gun
in the air about a 45 degree angle so if
he lowered his hand six inches he would
have hit our car why did he was he doing
that we have no [__] idea
Fender was hanging off
and then yeah well then a big [__]
truck came right in between us and we
like slowed down and let him go ahead I
don't know if he's shooting at us but he
was shooting at us he was shooting
toward us what's he shooting into just
Oblivion or were there possible people
or cars on the other side of the highway
that it looked like he was like just
being like I'm gonna [__] shoot my
gun off
it was immediately when we realized what
was happening it was so terrifying
because we would this CL he lowered his
Hanny
he was shooting like this
and we were just like we were all shook
we were like damn man once Shook Ones
you know Shook Ones mob deep
you surprised me
you surprised me I'm just on that cusp
of that late 90s rap I know that mob
deep was big for me yeah all the killers
mob deep all the killers in a hundred
dollar bills yeah Gangstar mob deep yeah
Eric sir all those Eric being Rock can't
like yeah I did I would never guess that
you knew yeah I know Queens yeah yeah
for sure for sure but I just feel like
you um well maybe you know them but
sometimes you don't know that you know
the song You Know The Artist like I I
never really hear you talk about music
like
at all mob deep is someone who when I
hear their songs I know I know Nas songs
sure those you know Jay-Z yeah when you
start to get into the rakims and uh I
don't know I know of them of course but
I don't know they're I'm not a hip-hop
Aficionado by the way speaking of
hip-hop shout out 94.7 The Block which
is on in New York City it's my favorite
radio station
um in the last 30 years if they're
listening and we know well Cipher sounds
uh does the 10 a.m to 2 p.m block Miss
Jones Miss Jones in the morning who I
used to listen to when I was a kid I
love Miss Jones Ed Lover at night it's
literally like shout out so shout out at
lover I used to listen to him all the
time again what are they spinning
Throwbacks 94.7 not now no only
Throwbacks I'll hit the preset with it
it's how our oldies were like when we
would listen to you know 101.1 CBS FM
the oldies dude those are our oldies now
you couldn't have hit the nail on the
head more yeah when we were born oh I'm
70s or 80s but like in the 80s the
oldies were the 50s yeah 30-year
difference right now 2023 30 years is
93. that's literally 36 Chambers Wu-Tang
It's the oldies literally yesterday or
two days ago I was in the car with my
son my stepson 12 years old and Usher is
on 94.7 and and it was like make him
want to lead
start a new relationship yeah this is
what you do think about it
so Usher is on and we're singing that
song I'm having a good time and you know
singing it together yeah yeah yeah
the back seat on his Rubik's Cube
and then he looks up and he goes who's
now it's like oh it's Usher you've never
heard of Usher and he goes is he from
SoundCloud and I was like
what and he goes is he from SoundCloud
and I was like no he's Usher he's like
he's been famous since he's like 15 16
years old I was like you've genuinely
never heard of Usher and he was like no
yeah but then he'll drop it like a is
this a tentacion yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know while he lists they like they I'm
telling you all the kids for Taylor
Swift is is a good example of someone
who is just she was famous when we were
younger and and we're not you know I
mean I'm older than her and she's still
famous now to the kids like she's she's
been famous as a singer the whole way
six Generations yeah she just knows yeah
everybody knows everybody's no t-swift
what uh what do you think well we gotta
yeah Chris okay did you see this yeah
Chris Brown and his crew they beat the
[__] out of Usher this is only two weeks
ago yeah oh yeah this was big news pimp
Texas right away there's pimp texting in
the photo oh my God that literally
looked like he was
is this real guys no this is real this
is real pimp this is real right actually
it's allegedly uh allegedly t-shirts
coming soon
wow I can't imagine because wouldn't he
go to jail like throwing a skate party
in Vegas who's skating who jumps Usher
have you noticed that that Trends change
races have you noticed that like skating
used to be a predominantly white kid
from California thing and now a lot of
black guys love to skate do you think
that's roller or or board I think it's
bored I think it's like things that you
or like or like it used to be like it
used to be like you know uh a lot of
black guys were wearing baggy clothes
now it's white people that wear baggy
clothes okay like Trends they they
whatever it's not it's just they change
races a lot like a trend will be
predominantly with One race for a long
time and then it moves to another race
social media and and all that used to be
a white thing now it's mainly it's it's
mostly a black thing a blacks are mostly
on social media more than whites that
they tell you to change races Trends
change races is that a joke dude the
touching of the glasses as you said that
I didn't believe it but when you went
like that I was like maybe it's true yep
yeah even being gay being gay used to be
multi a white thing now a lot of black
people are gay yeah it's a big thing
they were but we they didn't they
weren't comfortable saying it because of
the culture yeah it could be frowned
upon a little bit more now now we're all
Progressive but it goes It goes it all
is
it's back and forth you know it's back
and forth there's a lot of um and
there's a lot of crossover between
Italians and blacks I know that that
it's like it's interchangeable I listen
to the same music wearing the same
clothes it's all the same thing yeah
we're not that far apart I agree with
that
all right well we wish Usher well uh we
don't know how much he got messed up I
mean we'll see I mean you know he uh you
know he used to live with Michael
Jackson live with what yeah oh sorry
sorry P Diddy when he was when he was
when he was 11 or 12 the guy from his
record company a big guy that's the time
to live with Michael Jackson sent him to
live with P Diddy as a boy as a young
boy
and he lived in P Diddy's home
he left his parents because he wanted
him to see the lifestyle of P Diddy and
the work and the lifestyle and he went
and did he took him in I just shout out
Danny a week ago shout out Diddy did he
taking everybody in did you take in your
mama did he do it did he do it so
remember where is Diddy I don't know
what's he up to lately he's still
killing it somewhere yeah make it to
rock
he used to be in my life more
remember kids if not if not you then who
if not now then when that's what I want
you to take on your hey babe journey
through life today hey babe and then
yeah and then Remember Everything Will
Change races
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]